Est-ce qu'on a pas envie de jouer à quelques jeux vidéals ?
Oh j'ai envie de la faire debout, cette vidéo !
J'ai envie de la faire debout.
Mais j'ai pas le bureau euh cool, que les gens cool ont, là où tu peux le lever...
*bouge son bureau*
Non, il se passe rien
Aujourd'hui j'ai pris 3 jeux gratuits, bien nawak, mais qui vont bien nous faire kiffer..
Le premier s'appelle "Spherical Constitution"
Et il est.. over glauque... *rire nerveux*
Bon y'a une boule !
Et le but c'est de bouger l'endroit où est la boule
Pour la faire atteindre le trou, voilà
Bon là c'est simple, j'ai juste à pencher et ça atteint le truc..
Mais je pense que plus tard il faudra faire du gauche, droite hein..
Voilà.. y'a du blanc qui sort de son cul finalement..
Oh putain, qu'est-ce que je dis..
WTF !
Ah c'est horrible ce son mais oh !
*Convulse*
Ah ok, faut que je me penche comme ça en fait
Pour qu'elle aille dedans après
Je crois hein
En fait, les contrôles sont nuls à chier hein..
C'est pour ça que vous me voyez galérer
C'est vraiment des contrôles de merde
Pourquoi là elle est pas dedans, elle est dedans là, c'est quoi cette notion de la 3D ?
Je remets en question toutes les notions de 3D dans les jeux mec, j'en peux plus..
MAIS POURQUOI ELLE Y VA PAS ?!
C'est comme ça, c'est sûr c'est comme ça regardez
J'aiuntrucsurmajam ...
J'ai réussi ? D'accord j'ai même pas fait exprès..
Ça en dit long sur votre jeu monsieur
Non mais c'est quoi cette postion encore, holala
Et voilà ! Easy !
Alors là par contre là, c'est quand même c'est l'un des jeux le plus fumeux auquel on ait joué ces 2 derniers mois...
Non franchement mec
Oh putain, ça c'est un labyrinthe, ça j'adore mon gars
J'suis nul mais jadore
Ah mais là regardez y'a un p'tit pont, y'a un petit raccourci
On va prendre le petit pont
Je suis en train de try-hard sur ça, j'aime trop try-hard sur des jeux où c'est nul de try-hard
On va donner un peu d’élan
Hop Et HOP !
Et BOOOOOOOOOM
C'est quand même un bon jeu de fonsdé mec, ça c'est les gens qui vont dans les catacombes qui jouent à ça
C'est pas pour rien qu'on est en train d'y jouer !
Ah mais putain, ça part sur un délire de cercueil...Qu'est ce qu'il faut faire...
Ah le pied regardez il y a un trou dans le pied je pense qu'il faut bien viser
OH
OH ET BEN NON
Faut faire la passe?
Oh nan dommage!
mais attends ce jeu en fait, je commence à kiffer le jeu, est-ce que je dois m'inquiéter?
un peu ...
OOOHHHH c'est beau !
C'est beau ce passement de pied
Alors ce jeu est gratuit inutile de le préciser *rires*
Personne n'aurait payé pour ça
Nous sommes maintenant
après avoir laissé jouer Brad Pitt, il s'est vite barré d'ailleurs, il a vu
le potentiel du jeu....... NON
On est sur Jump Doper et on joue des objets qui font de la corde à sauter, voilà
Je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que la corde à sauter est quelque chose qui muscle énormément le corps
Et je le sais, pour preuve j'en fais jamais
"Press any key to jump"
Et voilà, et du coup le but c'est
de faire le plus de sauts
Le problème c'est que la corde à sauter nous coupe littéralement, voilà, par exemple j'ai fait 3
....
C'qui est nul.
Franchement si vous voulez devenir musclés
Faites de la corde à sauter tranchante j'avoue ça motive
Mais pourquoi je peux pas resauter?
Logiquement, c'est espace
Dans un jeu, quand on appuie sur espace, tu sautes
Ouais, j'ai... Vous avez entendu? J'ai fait ça: *appuie sur espace* pour être précis et le truc a pas sauté, mec
Regarde, Mec ça m'énerve.
Eh j'vais casser un truc!
Regarde! C'est un truc de...
Nan, vous savez quoi?Je vais dire "pile" dès que j'appuie sur espace, vous allez voir ça saute pas
Pile.
Je suis Brad Pitt.
Tain j'appuie tellement sur cette barre d'espace, j'ai envie de faire une musique là, mon gars
Eeehh, et si on faisait une musique?
C'est une grosse idée de merde !
Probablement la pire idée de l'histoire de ma chaîne
Je vais tourner le micro vers le clavier, ok, on va enregistrer
C'est vraiment malaisant *rires*
OK, là j'suis en train d'isoler chaque son un par un de manière à faire quelque chose de colossal
La barre espace,
La barre espace suivie d'une petite touche
La grosse basse
Voilà, et vous allez voir qu'avec ça, on va atteindre un truc de malade
OK, les amis, après 1 heure de travail acharné *rires*
Au final j'ai juste fait une vidéo où j'ai préféré faire un son que de jouer à des jeux
Mais je suis hyper fier du résultat, attention on écoute!
Soyez indulgents, merci, c'est parti!
Oh I Oh I Oh I Oh I !
I'm in love with your body
Merci à tous *rires*
Bon Squeezie, ta chaîne c'est du gaming, là tu fais plus de gaming, c'est n'importe quoi
OLA OLA OLA, tu vas te calmer toi !
T'écoutes du Ed Sheeran dans ton écouteur dans ta manche en 3ème et tu fais le malin?
On est sur Caramaritztzzz j'suis en train de jouer un p*tain de poulpe
et je m'amuse à faire la circulation, mon gars
Euh voilà, finalement si j'avais pas été YouTubeur, est-ce que j'aurais fait ça?
On ne sait pas
Le problème c'est que des fois, ils s'impatientent et du coup il râ- -.
OH OH OH, il est passé, j'lui ai même pas dit oui!
J'comprends rien.
Vas-y toi passe, toi passe, toi passe, toi passe, allez passez
MAIS NAN!
Mais mec, des fois y a des bus qui arrivent et y-y-y sèchent l'agent de police, c'est scandaleux!
Eh mais mec, ça demande trop de ressources de cerveau ça *rires*
Mais mon gars
Même ton I-7 Intel
X-28 il assume pas !
Et voilà
"PIRE AGENT DE LA CIRCULATION"......
"AU MONDE"
Et ça, ça veut dire
Abonnez-vous à la caîne de Squeezie, il est incroyable
Et voilààà le mec il s'impatiente, il part tout seul .
Mec putain je suis sur la route quand un flic fait LA CIRCU
Y a pas de "j'm' impatiente et j'passe" mon gars
Le gars il tape un sprint, il te rattrape
ouais parce que c'est un flic un peu venère.
Il te met un coup dans la nuque, mon pote !
Eh on fait mieux là ! On fait mieux nan ?
On a fait mieux on a fait 180
On est BIEEENN !
C'est super dur
Mais c'est super bien !
J'suis content j'vous ai montré un jeu qui- qui est pas mal
Mais j'en ai encore un !
*rires*
C'est un jeu où on joue un putain d'aspirateur mec
Il va falloir aspir-
Mais genre
Il part en couilles l'aspi- apparemment il est super puissant
Comment ça se joue par contre ?
Ah ok j'ai juste à le prendre et à le bouger
d'accord.
est-ce que vous mettez des vidéos de bruits d'aspirateur
Sur YouTube pour vous endormir ?
ça marche hyper bien
Donc là, faut que j'aspire ça? ce truc bleu ?
Aaahhh, mais déjà faut que je le branche mec.
Voilà
J'allume là...
ET BEN VOILA !
Ok j'ai aspiré un truc bleu !
Et j'crois qu'en fait le truc bleu ça va booster la puissance de l'aspi
Je vais aspirer tout et n’importe quoi derrière.
...
Voilà
Mais j'vous ai parlé d'un excellent jeu vidéo !
à quel moment j'ai menti ?
Regardez !
C'est pas un putain de jeu vidéo ?
La physique est trop bien faite regardez comme ça aspire !
Heureusement que j'ai pas fait d'école de commerce mon gars
J'aurais rien vendu !
J'aimerais bien aspirer la.. t'sais la maison entière !
J'suis sûr, Eh j'suis sûr que c'est la chute !
Si c'est la chute c'est le meilleur jeu de cette vidéo
Nan mais très clairement,
Que les choses soient claires
ah faut que je fasse tomber ce qu'il y a sur la table !
OUAIS OUAIS OUAIS OUAIS OUAIS
C'est le meilleur moment de cette vidéo c'est incroyable !
Allez !
Allez...
Ouuiiiiiii
Et on va aspirer ce qui y avait sur la
TAAABLE
OH !
Oh y avait un bouton secret mec !
Et ça a mis un truc bleu là
ça, ça va booster mon aspi mais un truc de malade !
OH PUTAIN
What The Fuck ?
Mais Nan !
C'est quoi ce délire ?
Quoi ?
Le objets sont vivants
OH MON DIEU J'ASPIRE TOUT !
C'est quoi ça ?
Mais c'est quoi cette vidéo ?
C'EST QUOI CE MARDI DE MERDE ?
Et bah les amis j'ai envie de vous dire que c'est la fin de cette vidéo
ET TANT MIEUX
On est content qu'elle se termine !
J'espère que ça vous a plu, si c'est le cas
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude !
En fait j'adore les mini jeux comme ceux qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
Mais je pensais qu'ils seraient quand même chacun un petit peu plus long
Et qu'ils auraient chacun un intérêt un peu plus grand.
Bah c'était clairement pas le cas
C'est scandaleux
Mais ça m'a plu
La vidéo scandaleuse on va l'appeler
Ahh Putain...
Avec une miniature avec des seins en gros plan comme ça ça fera
Et une flèche rouge ça fera plein de vues comme ça
Allez on se retrouve très vite pour une vidéo de bien meilleure qualité, portez vous bien !
Ciao tout le monde !
Peace!
*voix non virile*